gang quick announcement on the middle
class famous tour we are going to be
coming to a city near you for a live
stand-up show and playing ayg with the
audience we're going to be in san
francisco california los angeles
california la jolla california and we'll
also be in pittsburgh buffalo detroit
denver phoenix salt lake city chicago
then over there to roseman and that's
just to me we're going to be adding some
dates it's going to be a fantastic time
grab the squad come out and see us get
your tickets it's a good time welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts kevin ryan and h foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it if they grow it to be
classy yeah or if they're just a big old
piece of trash i'm your host dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
down here aunt toddy's basement she's
upstairs knocked out on the patio okay
yeah when i find this son of a [ __ ]
i got a little payback someone went
after her someone someone snuck her she
probably she probably has money on the
street that dumb abroad i don't know but
as a vendetta we gotta we gotta fulfill
yeah whose car are we taking it's like
five brothers or what's it called four
brothers they set her up they set hoodie
up it's a great flick my co-host is
coming at you from across the table he
is the ceo of ru garbage he's an
international businessman do me a favor
give it up for kevin
brian everybody
[Laughter]
it is butt life jacket
this is vintage this is this is old
school you look like you're triple
parked outside and just busted a case of
corona
looking for somebody to sign for this ah
this guy finally gets some cash starts
dressing like a t-ball coach if it's a
real dick of vibes should've got a boy's
head route [ __ ]
i'm an amoroso man myself
ah there's blood on the inside of this
thing as we speak from its previous
owners
i'm big into vintage beer gear hold on i
thought you were buying these new you're
buying these these are used yeah man the
the pops one was new this is this is
like yellow like the tag
a couple of softball games have been
coached in that oh yeah a couple of real
nail biters a couple of points been
shaved too i
you think that thing off the set of
beverly hills cop too jesus you stink
i'm living my best life let me be
that's all you have for us that's all i
got i mean i'm gonna take the beating
i'll just sit here and take it you know
what i mean i dished them out myself you
know
i'd be i'd be i'll just go sit back and
take it i'll you know do you i'll take
it we love it it looks like um guys as
always please make sure you rate review
subscribe that's what i was looking for
i was about to pick it up for you oh no
i thought you were about to hit him with
it i up to be honest i thought there was
going to be more [ __ ] wow that's it
lighthearted we're having a nice time
you're a good friend of ours
guys uh as you know please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are true
out at first
yeah
um and then uh obviously pine tar
i got a nail file i'm shaving the ball
uh he's got four more of these folks so
sit back because they're gonna keep
coming four don't you i got about nine
of these in the closet
this is my new personality by the way um
and then obviously i would be you're
you're you're jamming up the plugs i
apologize i'm trying to get to the
moneymaker the thing that keeps you you
fat in your apartment out there
patreon.com
are you garbage the greatest website of
all time you can sign up to get bonus
episodes ayg episodes of hard feelings
yeah by the way
we dropped a couple about a week or two
ago they rattled some cages everything's
all right the boys are okay uh guys
thanks for everything we love yous love
you both and how about a quick shout out
to our producer shortener the magic man
my best pal in the whole wide world and
i love them to death give it up for mr
toby mcmullen ladies and gentlemen
what's up dudes
good to see you sir you too i don't want
to take up too much too much time
kimmy's got some kegs to deliver so you
gotta keep moving dude i'm double parked
outside
you look like you definitely wouldn't be
checking ids when you dropped it off
checking id a couple of house parties
yeah no never have it you ever have a
keg delivered
no we would go get we'd have you know
an older uh that's real old-school [ __ ]
when they would deliver that was in the
movies in the 70s yeah yeah never we
never had that yeah leave it out front
we would go pick up cartoons inside
we would go pick up for sure yeah yeah
does anything move a keg better than a
wood paneled station wagon it's pretty
good
we were we had uh my buddy's old
suburban we called the dank tank
and uh
we would load them up in there but we
were a little [ __ ] so it took like six
of us to get it in the back because it
was all jacked up there was only one kid
that could ever tap it right too i was a
pretty good tapper i stunk at it that
was all foam you had a hit quick baby
i didn't get it i didn't get the science
behind it i didn't get what you're not a
science guy i didn't get what the tap
did or how it went in i always thought
it was weird [ __ ] yeah taps were like a
commodity at one point
under got the keg i don't got a tap yeah
everybody got tattoos calling her out
you're some dirtbag trunk of his mom's
car something's [ __ ] up and then
you're calling like jimmy jimmy you got
your tap what are you doing tonight come
on over you drink for give me a free cup
that's how the beer stores would get you
oh you don't got a tap why don't you get
a tab
yeah
cause i'm 12. they were like 45 bucks or
something if i remember which we didn't
have back in the day i meant when i was
a kid my parents my dad made it seem
like the return fees on those kegs were
eight million dollars
with with the urgency that he got the
cake i gotta get the gig back yeah i
gotta get your gig back
like what the [ __ ] man what was it a
nickel
back when i was banging they were 10
bucks a clip
10 bucks a clip and you would return it
and we would you'd get the 10 bucks back
and we would get a case of lions head
beer
which is a local that's operating
capital right yeah there you go put that
right back into the business i like that
so
if we had a party with like beer nuts if
we had a party with like uh you know say
saturday night we had three kegs or
whatever
three kegs yeah we would we would throw
bangers down there on edgely street
really bangers
sometimes it got a little it was all we
ah any ladies yeah there was one there
a real bruiser
beat us in arm wrestling every time
longest cake stand still records the
record still cooking that's why you're
the three kegs
big lucy would take two
yeah
just sitting in the corner with his
troll
kevin get over here
make out with me
making me make out of her
um we would do it in the basement of a
row home in north philadelphia was the
party
i mean went to town nothing good happens
in the basement no no
home i mean sometimes fight fights would
break out because like people would
bring friends and friends of friends and
friends from friends from home in
college were always the worst they
didn't know the etiquette they never
mixed they never friends from home from
college always got too [ __ ] up to the
point where they could become friends
but there would be a feud first well
yeah after years [ __ ] hated this dude
when i first met him yeah oh man there's
a lot of those there's people like we
fistful that i know this guy's all right
what's willie doing this weekend
every person who's ever met me thinks my
laugh is fake yeah well i've read the
youtube comments one of my one of my one
of my boys was like it was one of my
best friends now he's like i didn't
speak to you for five months because you
have the most annoying laugh on planet
earth
but a friend from a friend from home
would get too [ __ ] up like end up
peeing in the sit like he didn't know
the rule he just thought because they
were typically like community college or
like went straight to work the way i
personally they didn't know protocol
they were just like this is animal house
this is my bedroom dude what are you
doing [ __ ] live here man our friends
from high school were more degenerates
than their friends from college oh one
you know that old standing rule college
educated to a degree yeah yeah that's
where that's where the problem would lie
yeah yeah i mean my friend dumping
somebody's dishwasher yeah my friends
would come rolling in with like a
three-foot nitrous tank and a stun gun
not a lie
that was a party [ __ ] better cancel
class tomorrow yeah cause i'm staying
for like three four days yeah i gotta
get back to the [ __ ] you know no anybody
looks at me sideways getting zapped yeah
did you have anybody
did you have anybody that went to
college but didn't go to college you
haven't anybody i lived with yeah so
that stayed there i so
my first uh my first house the one i was
talking about my one boy from high
school went to like nine different
universities yeah for like two years
they always crap out and then just live
at one you dude you just lived there
yeah yeah so my boy that you met down in
orlando yeah you were like that guy's
[ __ ] movie good looking oh man he was
a looker today he lived with we lived
with him i grew up with him he lived we
lived together in college meet him and
flip and another weirdo uh yo we needed
one more guy to fill the bedroom and
this guy was a creep ola dude hey the ra
sent me over yeah he had real r.a vibes
hey lenny put your [ __ ] over there yeah
he was always like
you're sleeping on the desk he was
always like go wanna go to my room and
take shots we're like no way
your room has a deadbolt on it dude it's
not a [ __ ] goat you got an outdoor
doorknob on that thing
not going into your [ __ ] room
you have bars on the windows on the
inside no thanks
so
uh oh sorry whatever uh my friend
he crapped out right he took a semester
off after living there that's the kiss
of death and he moved that's how to
become a stripper right he moved his boy
in who didn't even attempt to enroll in
the university wait he took his room
yeah don't worry about the room i got a
guy i got a guy danny devito shows up
his boy moved in
and who and then this is how insane the
world was we were living in flip and
my friend who were living there
shared a room together
so then flip just had to share a room
with this new guy
like
so like boot camp and then he moved his
girl in and his girl she not moved her
in but she was just there a lot and she
was nice hold on were they sleeping in
the same room with flip yeah holy [ __ ]
yeah a lot of squeaky squeaky going on
there i think flip was fake sleeping a
lot of times i heard that's how flip got
involved with the movies
he had night cam goggles night vision on
night vision in a gully suit in the
corner um so
yeah so that i mean that was like that
year and then there was there was two
guys or one guy that just recently had
gotten out of prison
they were hanging down there a lot i'm
pretty sure they're not alive
they were hanging down they were showing
us how to make prison food with ramen
and making chi chi and i'm like what am
i i'm just going to run as a calf dude
yeah man i got fourth meal still if i
make to the calf by 11 i can make my own
chicken farm
i would take the chicken fingers a
little bit of the pasta sauce slice of
american cheese
and then with like three sodas and two
gatorades good night that's trash love
the cafeteria you know what i wanted to
ask you speaking of food what's that um
you me you you briefly mentioned that uh
around around easter yeah all right i'm
listening that you go down to the shore
with the family yes but what was your
because you were such a weird kid i'm a
weird guy what was your easter what of
it what was your easter basket situation
was there an egg hunt
what was the lineup um
the lineup i would open my mom would
middle
my brother would close it out with a q a
put a strip show um
uh it was pretty standard standard for
sure because my brother and sister were
normal i was the weird guy i could see
you being a real prick about your basket
yeah i mean the peeps could kick cough
drops hard-boiled eggs no way
give me like the the rags chocolate kind
of stuff yeah you wouldn't jelly beans
can kick rocks
at the bottom the grass is all in there
no thanks you're nuts i don't i don't
like anything loose give me something a
package i can open with an airtight seal
and i can squeeze it to make sure the
air doesn't sink in some scratchers yeah
um then we did uh hold on you're not a
hard-boiled egg guy
you wouldn't need a dyed egg
no oh he used to make eggs [ __ ]
egg salad with those i don't i don't
think a week later i've never had egg
salad really
never tuna salad chicken sauce i don't
like anything cold
i'm a weird man
what do you want from me
um you should be wearing those
headphones all the time
put that jacket on dude
it does look like you're listening to
the game right now whatever you do don't
mention
potato sound to him or he'll freak the
[ __ ] out
really taking it on the chin today boys
um
i uh
this is so we did have a uh a hunt you
know we would do like the plastic egg
where you would put like the jelly bean
a dollar a quarter sometimes sometimes
a dub would be in there well this is one
or two of them trashy we are i remember
um
my stepdad
wrote a hundred dollars like you know
dollar sign 100 on it and iou
no but then super glued it shut and i
couldn't i was like six i don't even
know what super glue was you know what i
mean let alone that like he could be
pulling the wool over my eyes just to
[ __ ] have him laughing keep you busy
for a couple of minutes oh dude i'm
sitting there [ __ ] i'm like it won't
come off i'm [ __ ] i'm like calling a
lawyer hit it right behind a wasp nest
it's on the roof
uh
yeah man i remember like i remember
being so [ __ ] pissed and he was like
and then there was nothing in there i
got [ __ ] stiffed on the hundo
yeah real [ __ ]
i'll never forget that you know what the
easter mvp is what that reese's egg dude
that was our cadbury eggs can kick rocks
just because the commercials freaked me
out with that goddamn bunny i love them
and that was one of my they're one of my
favorite you got a fresh one of those
fresh like when dries
recently made they're fantastic
there's a lot of candy like that that's
a lot it's a lot of candy the situation
is when was it made some of that [ __ ]
could be could be a year or two old
that's why you do get the holiday stuff
because it's usually fresher
okay i mean it's
how fresh you don't know you're assuming
you can taste the difference what if i
told you it was made eight months before
because i used to work at a chocolate
factory yeah and that talit yeah that
lead yeah t-bone's looking at me
somebody goes how many jobs has skippy
had
it's a lot
um the guy in quantum leap i'd never
seen it no i worked i spent a lot of
time in a chocolate factory so what's
this have to do with my listen it
doesn't come right it it doesn't [ __ ]
come off the line into a truck to the
cvs for you to eat i'm aware of that
straight into foley's bed
you're sitting there
like that little swedish boy from willy
wonka i'm squeezing them like bread
dude they sit in boxes and warehouses
for like two years i know so i'm saying
the ones so you're telling me you can
tell the difference between a cadbury
egg that was made two years ago and
eight years ago 100 how about two years
and three years well it's that's not
fresher anything that's two years old
isn't fresh well i mean comparatively
you made it seem like you were waiting
at the kitchen door like the you know
they were coming out with them
comparatively speaking i would say you
you can taste that difference okay and
they're usually the ones that are the
holiday ones they think they make figure
they make those less
all right you work for bud light you
tell me you know yeah [ __ ] said [ __ ]
sits on a shelf for a long time
i can't believe that that's used i'm
stunned that you're wearing a jacket
that has somebody else's blood on it
yeah you know i'm trying to make uh i
think it was a crime
there's a bullet hole in the back
a couple of stabbings i gotta get
patched up a little road rage incident
he will be eating this where he's going
it was a bad call what do you want
um
uh yeah i got a handful of really old
vint like proper vintage ones some of
them didn't hold up i gotta return them
or sell them or give them to a listener
if you would like i got a couple hit me
up some are just
too small or too big
you know the sizes back in the 70s were
all [ __ ] all over the place holler's
your boy dude i'll rock one
no no no i like that idea yeah you gotta
give one to toby then when we get in
fights with each other we can kick dirt
on each other
are you [ __ ] blind t-bone you call
that a clip you call that a clip kimmy
gets thrown out of the studio
hit the showers t-bone
you're off your meds
just sitting there doing the show big
thing a gatorade comes flying at me
a bunch of sunflower seeds are kicking
everywhere
[Music]
uh what would what would the meal be on
easter again um as we got older we
touched on this briefly yeah so we go so
now we go down to the shore uh
we go to wildwood
uh and then saturday we go to my aunt's
in sea aisle which you've been to yes i
have uh shout out aunt patty shout out
and petty lovely home uh we'll do ham
we'll do meatball like we'll do the
crock pot with like meatballs sausage
kobasa okay okay i'm listening typically
you know uh kobasa is done on the grill
in wildwood
the day of
and then brought over yeah i mean it's
15 minutes or whatever love it um serve
it cold
the kobasa yeah uh
i don't know i can't recall i say around
the the the sausage and meatballs that's
where i lie and you got like the rolls
the pre-sliced rolls sitting there i
know him a plate of [ __ ] provolone
and american cheese or a little parmesan
start sweating after some hours yeah
do that up ham's definitely floating
around then you got the [ __ ] dips you
got the you know the whole nine we did
ham scott a lot of booze too we use it
as a boozy it's a boozing holiday of
course we're having a cocktail lord's
day a couple bloody bloody marys what's
going on say that three times in front
of the mirror when you're all [ __ ] up
scallop potatoes into the easter bunny
scalloped potatoes was big
and we would do a pineapple is this a
dinner this this is this is a formal
dinner coleslaw we don't do a sit down
ours is more of a
stan there's so much there's just too
many people it's like a buffet there's
like so many lawn chairs you know what i
mean i know yeah oh so many of those
brown metal folding chairs those get
broken out our family's just too big
every event is minimum
30 adults and
at this point 30 kids so it's like chaos
the guys are in the on the back deck
hanging out there's typically some golf
going on downstairs in the tv room
aren't the masters always on easter
we're a big golf family so they're kind
of coming up tigers here mickelson's
here [ __ ] a lot of new short sleeve
button downs getting broken out yeah a
lot of plaid a lot of spring yeah yeah
yeah yeah for sure i like that uh-huh
pretty classy pretty good pretty all
right
good shot always dip dipping away for a
couple of heaters with the with the boys
sneaking out coming back because now all
the sauvignon blanc all that all the
all the cousins like the cousins of of
my age
to all crank heater who crank bernies
they all have like seven eight-year-old
kids running around
so they gotta duck around we gotta go
around the corner or duck behind a car
because they don't want their kids
knowing they're they're [ __ ] dabbled
in there let me ask you this do you have
anything do you have anybody in the
generation below you
that has aged into heaters
have you witnessed that
last time you saw him he was 16 now he's
20. is he smoking
no i think the oldest
one of the generation below me is
probably
i mean they're definitely boozing just
dipping just dipping on the weekend he's
a weekend warrior uh i'm sure they're
gonna do a little lip i i know i mean i
know some of the teenagers are
definitely boozing and stuff like that
yeah because they disappear like we used
to oh we're going to run back over to
the house we forgot the whatever a lot
of errands yeah a lot of errors there's
always six white claws missing i don't
know what's happening nine kids going to
get a bag of ice come on we know what
you're doing
save a toke for uncle hank
let's talk about movement move man talk
about movement talk about two young
college dropouts trying to turn the
watch game upside down and that's
exactly what they did with movement i'm
a big watch guy i know that movement
makes nice pieces
at a fraction of the cost fair prices
fair prices unexpected colors unexpected
colors now they're in the sunglasses you
go over their website they got
everything you need top quality looking
stuff at a good rate yes movement
watches uh have the look and quality of
a 400 to 500 dollar watch you're paying
watch you you're paying for at a
department store but a fraction of the
cost of the price because they were they
were built online and use their own
process from start to finish no middle
man go and write that as song
they also have the blue light glasses
they were nice enough to send us watches
and glasses my lady loves loves the blue
light she's at the computer all day
working uh the ever squirrel blue light
filtering glasses are a game changer
really helps with eye strain and poor
sleeping patterns uh in a modern style
frame if you want to elevate your look
with that style that doesn't break the
bank then join movement and get 15 off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to mvmt.com garbage
again that's
mvmt.com garbage do it yeah gang let's
talk about butcher boxes let's talk
about butcher box let's talk about a
meat or a freezer full of meat
salmon wild caught
organic turkey chicken
ground beef yeah ground beef speed bumps
pick it up ground beef coming out of
your ears i know just made a nice
rigatoni with some quinoa pasta the
other night delicious love butcher box
they're fantastic uh like you said they
were nice enough they sent us a freezer
full of stuff whatever you need from a
to z uh it's uh high quality meat better
taste more ethical more sustainable the
whole nine yards no any bee no
antibiotics nope no hormones nope each
box contains eight to 14 pounds of meat
depending on the box you choose that's
enough for 24 individual meals packed
for our ship frozen for convenience so
you can save time uh and energy on your
next grocery store trip customize your
own box or go with the ones they got
already either way you're getting
exactly what you want yeah this this is
this is bonkos
this is good this is your chance to
never have to shop for ground beef again
this is how are they staying in business
that's right folks butcher box is giving
new members free ground beef for life
and it's the good stuff it's the good
meat it comes the little square deep red
color good fat marbleization throughout
the ground beef i'm telling you it's
awesome plus you get a ten dollar off
coupon sign up at butcherbox.com ayg and
get uh
two
pounds of ground beef free in every
order for the life of your membership
plus a ten dollar coupon log on to
this deal do butcherbox.com that was
always that was always like the [ __ ]
work of a party in down the shore
because ci but we used it as our
advantage to catch heaters
because parking spots are big down there
too so you got to take the bike
everywhere which you don't mind because
it adds to the trip more heaters
plus you got the kids you got the gang
with you you got the squat everybody
rolls out a couple of burnies good stuff
it's a good time we had this one cookie
that was big it was it was like every
family got one sounds like a hell of a
dinner it was like a big shortbread
cookie with a hard-boiled egg in the
center what it was some kind of italian
thing
they're pretty good though i don't know
t-bone you looking that up we don't
really mess with italian easter cookie
with egg in the middle
sicilian
cutter
italian easter cookie there you go this
is the worst thing that's ever been made
i'm telling you they're [ __ ]
delicious
it's like an awesome shortbread cookie
with an egg in it yeah the hearts eat
the egg i don't know if you're supposed
to i did
that wasn't even cooked henry
i mean they they really hit gold with
pasta but they [ __ ] missed on this
one i'm telling you man it's good i know
in puerto rico they give the kids little
chicks little little baby chickens we
did that
no you didn't yeah oh that's right you
told me you did that with chicks and
ducks somebody would go down there and
get one um yeah my go to like a poultry
place in north philly wouldn't you no we
would go save them from the slaughter no
it was like davis feed mill or something
out in like the so
we live in the burbs but like right
about like it's like all suburban but
right above us is like kind of country
they're not country but like more farm
more rural that was back when we were
kids now it's all developed but there
was like a feed mill i should get a baby
duck that'd be awesome
what would you do with it would they
grow up would you give them away the
chick died the first night he tried
getting out and broke his neck
made hell of an omelette though that
sounds like epstein
that's weird all the cameras
two guys decided to take lunch at the
same time yeah weird i've never had a
pet that broke its neck well it was
jesus christ kevin oh we didn't know
yeah i don't know it died it was too
probably too young for us to have it he
broke his neck psycho no i didn't relax
we didn't know what we were doing with
it i mean we put it in like a we put it
in a fish tank we didn't know what the
[ __ ] we were doing with it
i think it you know put in a cool lift
thing yeah called it a day i and then
the ducks we kept for a while then they
got too big where did they
put them in a pond where did where did
you we had chicken we had a chicken wire
in the backyard
this is in the spring i guess that's
crazy you had ducks yeah who where would
you feed them
i don't know spaghettios
[Laughter]
don't ducks need water like don't they
have to live in did you have like a baby
pool or something out there don't act
like this isn't i'm trying
i'm being insane with this line of
questions i'm trying to know you're 12
years i don't know you kept ducks trying
to remember sitting with l.l bean over
here
i didn't know that
ralph lauren yeah
like a jay peterman
yeah we had ducks i think i told you and
then we at some point they got too big
and a little violent if you ask me for
my taste
ah
heard loud music coming from the
backyard
out there smoking and drinking all hours
people stopping by
there's a couple of carjackings we
couldn't pin it on them but
um
my radio was missing
uh no we yeah then we at some point they
were in a pen in the backyard i'm
assuming there was some sort of water
source for them yeah for sure but then i
think my mom i don't know what she was
like this is nuts yeah
well so my sister-in-law it's crazy to
have a duck let alone multiple ducks
yeah that's that's what's throwing me
off yeah and the chicken mysteriously
dies
the ducks died huh
no
but then we took him to a pond with so
my sister and all her friends got i
think we mentioned this my sister and
all of her friends got them this for
easter that was like what they were
doing i don't thought they were like a
nickel so they all got them thinking to
be cute and then my sister-in-law my
sister okay and then at some point they
all got too big and everybody all the
parents were like this is
you have [ __ ] wild birds at the house
this is
but that's nuts so we all put them in a
somebody had a pond in there like their
backyard like a forest okay we're like
oh just put them in here and we did that
then we went and visit them and i got
attacked by one of baby in the back of
the leg i ran do you ever see those
videos with the bird chasing the kid
that happened to me this [ __ ]
this thing came bee-line he could smell
the fear or the pee and he was holding a
two-foot hoagie at the time now oh no
wait wait wait didn't drop the hoagie in
my in my head he had an apron covered in
chocolate from the bachelorette
could be you have real food taken by
animals vibes as a kid
you really do man
you dropping your [ __ ] and running like
a [ __ ] oh i've run i still run from
birds i'll hit the deck
i don't [ __ ] with them man i really
don't throw your funnel cake and beat it
it's never what they want though seagull
with a mouth full of cheese fries and a
little fat angry gibby screaming on the
boardwalk
ah
that's good stuff yeah what do you want
from me all right nothing
all right let's get into some cues oh
[ __ ] you're right do a couple of cuesies
here as you know when you sign up for
the old patreon you get your question
right on the air on air on the air um
all right this is uh this is from mike
uh have you ever padded and pet your
dashboard like a dog and said it's okay
girl you got this i talked to my
talk in my car all the time yeah as far
as i'm concerned my car is alive
especially this one i have a very very
strong connection with it yeah
also crazy i think he's more respond
more referring to a car that's in bad
shape
oh where you're like you gotta coax it
into because my chevy loom in a 96 chevy
lumen oh yeah you gotta yay when you're
gonna finesse her well
second i think the second gear was a
little wonky
so you had to blast through it right to
third no
um growing up there was this kid that
didn't have reverse in his he drove a
conversion van to school like it's what
he drove
and he just had to cut he there was no i
swear to god there was no reverse in it
so he just kind of had to constantly
loop around and look for parking spots
that he could pull out of well if
somebody pulls it ahead of you you're
screwing like no he would pull front
into a spot that he could then like pull
out of or he would he'd have to park it
on the street he couldn't park it in the
driveway because he couldn't get out
that kid definitely worked on the
weekends dude
i think a weekday i think he was working
before school too
he was going in and opening up the shop
look at larry bird out there
yeah that's awesome yeah it was bad uh
also don't think he's alive i could be
wrong though um
man
the kids i grew up with drop like flies
there was a
most of them made it through high school
but then once we got into our 20s things
got real [ __ ] hairy i don't know if
it's the jacket but you're a real ray of
sunshine today
you mentioned the eod
i didn't say
i said he's no longer with us he didn't
it was his blood yeah come on read
between the lines yeah it wasn't septus
i could tell you that
this is a parachuting accident
he wasn't on his speed boat okay
speed ball maybe exact couple of high
balls
hot shots
the autopsy was waved uh i used to have
to do it with my chevy lumina up hills
because i think it was from second to
third
second was shot
so you kind of really ha and if you came
off the gas before you got to third gear
it
like it would just the engine would rev
and you wouldn't really accelerate
so
going up hills i really had to be like
two or three steps ahead to be like all
right baby we got a [ __ ] blasting
yeah we gotta we gotta [ __ ] start
getting some momentum here daddy oh
let's get off the top of this hill
everyone's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing like nah trust me this is that
well everybody knew it everybody knew at
that point it was a car nobody could
drive because
she had certain you know you had to know
her i've never started a car confidently
i don't think i'm always expecting it to
not start
yeah well now this is the first car the
key is the first new car i have so i
have no [ __ ]
turning and burning no sweat on that but
the montego
that thing
that was a roll of the dice at all times
lady had a little thing the other day
she's been were you with me at one point
in that yeah you're a starter or
something's going on yeah you're with me
that's just she didn't start
panicking yeah it just happened
sometimes it's been happening turning
volume i'll tell you why what i'm all
for the the the green energy and moving
forward it's that goddamn [ __ ] button
that you that it's it's the that it
kills everything when you're at a stop
sign yeah you hate that i [ __ ] hate
that where they when you're idling it
shuts down shuts down and then that's
got to do something bad to the car
don't then why would the car manufacture
i'm not saying you're wrong but like i
turn it off okay that's just a button to
turn it off but i think that's what it
is it's what it feels like it is
and this is from your professional
opinion yes okay just checking
for my many years yeah being a fat piece
of chef uh-huh
which i am i didn't say that and i i
don't think i've made one fat joke thus
far pretty good i think i did call you
fat in the intro but i was taking a lot
of you got carp launched
i'm still shaking off my t-bone guilt um
all right this one's from jimmy dean
ever
own a product advertised by billy mays
[Laughter]
we got flex seal right now that wasn't
billy mays sure it was flex seal was
billy mays dude i thought it was that
old other guy i think they did the boat
no that's billy that was billy wouldn't
build billy mays cornerstones i thought
he made his bones with oxiclean ah which
i used this morning to clean my nikes
yeah that my wife ruined billy mays did
not do i don't see flex seal by using
him flex tape
oh flex tape he did flex tape was flex
tape first maybe
maybe he also did mighty putty he's got
his fingers in a lot of pies that billy
mays right here yeah i could move some
[ __ ] units this figures in a bag of
yak yak do apparently no no wasn't it
something he got hit in the head like
his head on a luggage thing or like
luggage fell and hit his head or
something really i think on a plane at
landing i could be making all of this
out i thought he was knee-deep in an
eight ball no i might have to cut that
that beard too man that beard was solid
that dude he like that was just for men
he had it
whatever it was whatever those guys need
that guy [ __ ] had it well you know
what they do they make their bones in
the [ __ ] you've talked about the
trade shows
which i've also done
step right up step right in back when i
was running train shows out of the
valley forge conventions i was in valley
forge i was in ac it was in delaware i
was in i was in jersey and i they turned
a hockey rink into one and i would like
you to write down all your jobs
okay write down everything that you've
ever done we'll do it we'll show the
next bonus so we can have a master list
okay
in case you start getting lippy
what are you gonna send me back to santo
palato talk about the time you were a
fishing boat captain
i never said i was first mate
uh billy mays did not die in a
cartoonish plane incident he did however
pass away from a heart attack in his
sleep going to bed at his tampa condo
look up what happened to him the day
before okay
there was something with an airplane and
luggage fell on his head
i don't know if they ever connected
those two
if there was foul play
same guy
did your little chickling
uh nothing on it oh he was coked up
was he
thank you wow
i don't mean to discredit the they're
hey
but to be fair if you die in a tampa
condo at 50 and drugs aren't involved
that's a bad loss that's a news story
yeah
local guy passes away
no [ __ ]
what biker gang got him
and i just hold h crap up really
cocaine was involved and they found in
the autopsy yeah
damn
well you win some you lose some those
autopsies don't keep their mouth shuts
today
should have used some of that flex plug
yeah
oh yeah
there's no lying to him yeah you got
around to spin it afterwards oh yeah no
you got to take whatever narrative is
thrown at you
you and your estate i'm going to do
several pre-taped spin zones of of how i
might possibly die so i can i i can play
when i'm dead put like pop it in the
visuals
yeah i was holding it in my nose for a
friend
[Music]
that would be what you leave me in your
will what clips to subtitle
yes hey can you subtitle this for me
t-bone
would you want to be the guy that got
that for anybody what like like if i
went if you had to go sit with the the
estate guy and there was some nefarious
things here's a tape that you have to to
burn or here's here here's here's what
he wants an envelope or something of
your dying last wish yeah
uh no but it would for sure be me it
would be left to me to still clean up
your mess after you're [ __ ] dead and
gone i gotta fix your mouth i also got
laundry at the laundromat
you're somehow somehow giving me
attitude in a letter
hey what's up baldi probably wearing one
of those dumb jackets
hey [ __ ] i got two amazon packages
coming later today
don't open them
just leave them at the gravesite
bring them upstairs because my
neighbor's a little handsy
oh man when you go i'm gonna have to
deal with so much [ __ ]
you know that for sure
the longer you get out of me i think the
better it's gonna be buddy it's not if
it happens in the next six months yeah
you're gonna have a lot of a lot of
cleanup a lot of cleanup
our social security numbers are tied
together in this goddamn business oh
[ __ ]
it's like that dna video in jurassic
park mix it together
kevin oh man dude also if you go the
[ __ ] foleys are gonna be coming out
of the woodwork the wet dirt
not to mention the tell-all book
it's already written
trashing the [ __ ] out of you i hear
kimby doesn't even drink he just wears
those jackets
oh yeah you probably you're probably
gonna have all the print out of our text
and [ __ ] me [ __ ] voice recordings of
me screaming at you
do you have a will also this just did we
set the date
on the patreon we're going to have a
financial advisor come sit down with us
and go over our finances and get us
on track to a road to
you know sound financial planning yes
planning for retirement yes
investments 100 bull markets investments
uh yeah like what you should vending
machines
you said that one time like we could
open up a laundromat and someone's like
his thought products that's good
business of success it's opening it's
hey i knew a couple guys that owned
laundromats in my hometown they did
pretty guy on my block
right
make your own hours we had uh retails
tough retails tough though you can't
trust everybody you got to be there you
can't trust anyone okay everybody steals
from me in retail especially cash
business like a laundromat yeah
hey how many you know how many [ __ ]
just listen to their pockets on the way
out
[Laughter]
hey barry can i talk to you for a minute
bespoke post bespoke post box of awesome
ladies and gentlemen bespoke post box of
awesome will make you 10 degrees cooler
easy easy springtime what do you think
is coming in at around springtime cool
spring stuff yeah pocket nice outdoor
stuff stuff for the bar it's going to be
part barbecue with grooming materials
yeah smelling fresh looking fresh
feeling fresh box are awesome from our
good friends at bespoke post you got to
get on it yeah to get started just take
the bot just take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
there you go they release new boxes
every month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued at around
70 bucks but it doesn't cost that
fraction at a price you get it for
good guys over and gals over there love
a fraction of the price uh plus with
bosch of awesome you're supporting small
business 90 of everything that comes
from box of awesome is from a small
up-and-coming brand it's free to sign up
skip a month at any time or cancel
whatever you want to do get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome dot com enter the code
garbage at check out that's box of
awesome dot com code garbage for 20 off
your first box one more time write it
down box of awesome.com code garbage do
it athletic greens ag-1 let me tell you
why i started taking athletic greens
why's that one as you know we're portly
gentlemen sure it was time to get my
health in check i started working out
yeah i noticed when i was going to the
gym and working out i was still feeling
a little bit tired even when i just
drank water or whatever i tried to stay
hydrated switched over to athletic
greens they sent us they sent us a bunch
like popeye i used it for a month throw
it in there real easy shake it up tastes
great one stop shop vitamins endurance
immunity
gut health the whole nine yards i
noticed a specific difference when i
drink athletic greens throughout my
workout that i feel better and i last
longer yes 75 high quality vitamins
minerals whole foods source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens not in the
bedroom take that to the bank yeah it's
lifestyle uh friendly whether you eat
keto paleo vegan dairy-free or
gluten-free contains less than one gram
of sugars yep uh no nasty chemicals no
artificial flavor why still tasting good
if the big man likes it i like it you
know it tastes good are we doing let's
go right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition swimsuit
seasons come on just one scoop and a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills hey did i take
this i take that ag one's got you
covered just one stop shop to make it
easy athletic greens are going to give
you a free one-year supply of immune
boost
moon immune boosting vitamin d and five
free travel packs for your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com garbage again that's
athleticgreens.com garbage take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
back to the show back to the show but he
i was i remember they had like a really
nice house we had our house was nice but
like very basic it's just like you know
they had like the land your house is
like a doll's house yeah it's pretty
good if you hadn't played with your
dolls in like five years yeah um
there's they had like the landscape they
had like the street lamp like out front
you know what i mean like at the
beginning of their driveway they had
like a big brick touches
everything done real well and i remember
gonna ask my dad go what the i was like
eight i'm like what the [ __ ] does this
guy do you know what i mean because we
were real big about figuring out money
and what's that guy do what's this guy
do
i go what's a bunch of little dirt balls
in the back of the car
and he's like well when you grow up like
my dad owned a business
so
like that was his life 24 7. so it's
like everything revolves around
that business that business is your life
you know of course so it's like you're
in the car taking calls like you know
we're going to job sites drive around
look at commercial property think if you
want to buy it or not yeah we were never
that far ahead um
we were more looking at [ __ ] vending
machines and [ __ ] but i was like what's
he doing because he owns a couple of
laundromats and i was like
there you go had a good looking lady
with him there you go yeah i was like
this guy's [ __ ] doing it there you go
he was one of those italian dudes were
like jean shorts out like dress nicely
probably a second marriage for sure no
no no dress nice to do yard work you
know what i mean like hair was done
like nice i'm like this guy's [ __ ]
those guys that do their yard work
that's a different breed they keep it
looking real tight yeah they do it all
themselves we do ours but it looks like
[ __ ]
it was my job and i didn't care how many
times i cut just the front yard to get
my mom off my back so with our neighbors
she goes we look like [ __ ] bums what
are you doing so i would just cut the
front yard and go back to whatever party
i was at
cutting the grass at night is a tough
look too didn't even have to put your
sandwich in the fridge i just left it
right there on the plate
ah we'll be back in 20. we had the
oldest john deere tractor dude this
thing was [ __ ] from nothing yeah it's
he had a tractor dick i know i know i
know but john deere too we had to jump
it every time to start it
huh we had to literally jump the tractor
with one of the parked cars and if if
everybody was gone you could do that if
everybody was gone yeah i was seven
jumping a [ __ ] 1972 [ __ ] john
deere tractor
the seat was all rattler out there oh
dude the seat was all [ __ ] chipped
away and [ __ ] just metal
[Music]
that just had like the two that's pretty
classy but this is my life those hit in
the 90s hard yes this is this describes
my classy verse trashy life
in my head i'm like oh we have
we have this cool new piece of
technology that can jump a car without
another car
but we're using it to jump the old
tractor every week yeah usually the guys
that had those never used them they were
just in the back of their audi's or
something oh we use it all the time i
mean i used it weekly and then you'd
have to charge that thing and if that
thing wasn't charged it was a [ __ ]
yeah it was a lot
i felt like i was managing a [ __ ] a
mechanic shop watching tv of one of
those things
um
all right this one is from casey
uh
do you or anyone you know live by a code
of honor
[Laughter]
is there anything
i have i do have buddies like that where
it's like you don't
[ __ ]
say this about my fam or like very weird
guidelines where they they try to live
by they think it's like you know they're
you know they think they're like taking
over the west it's not yellowstone you
know what i mean it's like buddy relax
code of honor rob plow in the stars or
something no no yeah
don't know anybody
unless i don't know i don't know if i
have no i don't know
guys that live by that tend to tell you
like you won't disrespect my name you
know
maybe i don't know if i have any
samurais in the family
[Laughter]
no
i don't think any of us
would
subscribe to that but you can call you
can say anything
about any one of my like i i'm so like
but we do we do all abide by
like the certain unwritten rules of
comedy
yeah yeah it's true you have those like
no kids either what like hurting kids or
making fun of kids or anything like that
or i'll make fun of a kid
treating kids like adults ever like that
might be my one thing treating kids like
adults yeah i don't know what that means
like talking to and like like not
yelling at a kid but like
they're always considered kids and
they're always taken with a grain of
salt not a grain of salt um
handled with kid gloves yes you're
always nice to them like you know you
would never like you know
like reprimand somebody else's kid or
anything like that
does that make sense i'm not
articulating it well no i catch a kid
slipping around me i'm letting the
little [ __ ] know what time it is like
hey man don't do that no i'm going to
punch him right now
[ __ ] leg dropped this [ __ ]
what i'm talking yeah we have a very
open parenting part like i said our my
family's so big that all the kids
anybody can get
any adult no your family's different
i meant like strange like different
stranger kids stranger strange kids
don't even exist in my eyes yeah no i
don't yeah outside kids i don't you know
i don't [ __ ] i don't pay attention to
anybody that's my thing i've just seen
adults talk to
kids that they didn't know as if they
were adults
can you give me examples like hey do you
have owned bitcoin or like
they're like i don't understand what you
mean or like yelling at them like yeah
yelling at them is it like don't put
your feet on the
door i don't know not even [ __ ] like
that just like you know like hey man i
was there like you know if the kid like
staggered in in like a grocery store
line or something like that
you know what i mean i guess man i'm not
explaining it right yep like just be
we've given you three minutes too and
you can't get there
i don't think it's happening big guy
that's my only code
i'm nice to kids that's my code okay
there you go that's not a code that in
the yakuza
i look over here in a black dot your
black suit
two oozies on the table uh this one's
just funny this is the yakuza that's why
i think that's the one i'd want to be in
if you had your choice they're gentlemen
real class really quiet like they don't
they're not all they're not all up in
your face real just around you and
you're jammed up would that be what what
what uh
organized crime organization would you
want to be in
italian mob
there's so much romance behind the
italian mob with all the movies and you
know the 70s and 80s and stuff like that
um
yeah that would be fun
i guess but what is it did you get the
italian mob you got the yakuza i think i
would definitely go yakuza get to live
in japan i don't know dinner real late
one of the cartels might be pretty fun
too
but you really got to throw everything
to the wind at the car i don't have the
heart for that yeah no [ __ ] i feel like
the car tells you i would be like a
second
yeah that's kind of you know
she in a bathroom with a chainsaw like
fellas it's moving a little faster yeah
this is [ __ ] i'll give a noogie or
something give him a wedgie
i would join
those crooks down in washington dc the
biggest gang
senator to mcmullen
[Laughter]
you just bought 35 shares of an oil
field in
you know
afghanistan
oh wouldn't it suck if that was how we
were wow
yeah that's it there's no fun in that
those guys are bozos yeah yakuza gets
nice tables at restaurants i would join
uh
i don't know man like i said i've been
watching yellowstone that seems like a
pretty fun life battle rustler being a
ranch hand who dab like that the code is
the ranch is above everything uh-huh
right people are trying to steal the
land people trying to steal their cattle
this whole thing and it's like they're
coming i'll get this show doesn't it
take place now yeah who's muscling him
out of his land big business can you
just sue them
what's with all the gunfights this is
the wild west
things are different out there i thought
they were in ohio if you look over i'm
on a horse
[Laughter]
get this guy get a cease and desist
order
we need a couple of them are filed we
don't need to be torching each other's
barns anymore
you would think that
but you need to you got to send a
message somehow
lawyers take a long time you know what
doesn't molotov cocktail
i mean if you're plugging up somebody's
stream to [ __ ] dry them out
that's pretty medieval that's chess all
right
hey they didn't build the casino there
did they
i gonna run a casino with no with no
water who the hell wants to go to that
resort
[Laughter]
couple sticks of dynamite make that make
that creek make it left you know what i
mean
did they do that on there they did
something with dynamite where they blew
something up yeah
they read just they reworked the crick
and they couldn't build the resort there
because who the hell wants to say to dry
resort i need a babble in brook you know
what i mean these yuppies coming in from
l.a i'm telling you it's a good show
check it out kevin costner [ __ ] that
guy that guy's got some ch oh yeah it
does it's got all kippy fired up he had
me cut the power tuesdays with stories
i start
i start going yellowstone on other
podcasts
i brand t-bone
he's mine he'll always wear the ayg mark
it's just a trash can
[Laughter]
a good time you're having a good time
i'm having a good time all right
this has been a wacky one
um
this one i'll divert to you this is from
joseph uh is it garbage to combine fast
food with homemade food for dinner yeah
that's bad right you can't do that i
guess what would you do if you had like
a big mac and like
a side of
i don't know
mashed potatoes or something the only i
assume that would the
i assume the entree the the main dish
the protein would be from the
would be from the fast food right i
don't know you have i i've known people
that uh like would make like a hamburger
at home but have fries left over from
mcdonald's and throw them in the oven
and [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] has fries
left over from mcdonald's i don't this
goes back to the
i eat it all or i eat till i can't eat
anymore i eat it all unless i don't like
it
i wait a table this [ __ ] would take home
a half a thing of fries i waited tables
with with a girl that used to mix and
match
different leftovers in a pan and do them
up the only thing my wife does that the
only thing i can do that with is chinese
food i could take the fr if i have like
fried rice left over maybe some
dumplings or something like that i can
throw all the same country or something
i throw all the fried rice in the pan
and throw the dumplings in there let
them heat up and then a little hot sauce
over the whole thing make like a little
bowl out of it my wife will do that's it
my wife will do if we have like [ __ ]
but there's a half of a cold mcdonald's
hamburger in the refrigerator i'm just
gonna house that
yeah i would argue will you live in a
world where there's not gonna be a half
of a [ __ ] mcdonald's hamburger in the
fridge the orders were getting pretty
big towards the end there so you'd be
mistaken on that okay senator okay my
apologies sorry moving on
um sorry i'm a little nervous first time
i sat there with tony larussa
what
come on
no idea who that is
yeah
should have said tony hawk or something
maybe he would have got it huh hippie
[Laughter]
all right big man's back speaking of
foley dating himself in the car he
admitted to me that he's never seen the
mighty ducks everyone bully him online
whoa
i'm gonna check it out though
i'm gonna check it out
maybe tonight i think it's playing down
the paragon
[Laughter]
a cherry pop and some switzers please uh
yeah it's a great film i mean also it's
one of those things where like i was at
the like i was at the age of the guy of
the kids in the movie
playing hockey like it was like the most
[ __ ] which is what i was trying to
explain to him in the car uh was that i
was 10 years older than that so i looked
at that stuff like stupid kitty [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean
maybe weird red dawn was my mighty ducks
yeah
soviet invasion continental united
states
and a crack commando insurgent force
it seems like a lot of family fun
led by matt dillon and c thomas howe i
watched you pull
a storm trooper action figure out of
your pocket to go through security at
the airport and you're talking to me
about little kitchen well they get guns
on them what do you want me to do
you gotta check them
can't bring a phaser blaster on a
commercial flight what are you nuts
[Laughter]
relax my lightsaber is off
i don't want anybody to get you're like
the comic book guy from the simpsons
going through [ __ ] security
[Laughter]
i will need 12 more sheets
please don't touch my super belt
it's deactivated at the moment that's
funny i just watched that episode the
other day where he returns the ultimate
belt and we were talking about in the
car he goes into the store he's like i
like to return this quote-unquote
ultimate belt and the guy goes do you
ever receipt quote-unquote sir
is that the one where
bart has it right does bart have one
takes it to school and he takes it to
school in the bull and nelson the
bullies are chasing him yeah he's like
how to lose him and puts the left turn
signal on but turned right i'll never
forget that
he's going left
[Laughter]
they can't they catch him now
they got them they they always get them
and then homer gets beat up by their
dads who look just like them
um
all right this one's just funny this is
from mclovin uh is it garb just start
smoking after buying a bernie's
sweatshirt yeah i don't want to
encourage jesus christ i don't encourage
anybody to start smoking i'm trying to
never smoke who starts smoking and
they're when they're an adult that's
crazy pretty cool dudes i guess i don't
know i wouldn't suggest that to anybody
of course not don't do that
unless philip morris gets on board
then i'll push anything
money that's
an ag-1 ladies and gentlemen money talks
baby get me down in front of congress um
all right let's see here
this is good this is from brendan uh hey
fellas just joined the patreon no
question just this the sound of a
lighter tumbling in the dryer
[Laughter]
dude that's how you find them that's oh
man i've been busted from three blocks
away that's got me busted that's how you
get knocked yeah
what is that oh [ __ ] yeah yeah i swear i
was just starting fires
i was just burning down the old mill
yeah that's what gets you knocked yeah
um
this is all right let's do one or two
more than we got is skid edies
um
this is from lando i haven't had one
read yet
have you ever gotten out of your car to
move a construction slash road closed
sign so you can drive through a buddy of
mine did this and drove his car into wet
cement
that's a tough look oh they freak out on
youtube what the [ __ ] are you doing
and that's thousands of dollars in
damage unless you probably have to pay
for them as well to redo that [ __ ] that
i'm backing the [ __ ] out of there and
it's coasting i guess but what if you're
all what if you're [ __ ] scammed up
they got you yeah yeah you got to get we
got to get the hose on that quick you're
at their mercy unless you're close
yeah
that's tough
they do it there's a guy who does who
blocks uh
there's a homeless guy or you know one
of the a street guy down in the village
that blocks mcdougall street do you ever
see that no yeah
he blocks it so it's like he has clients
that'll come in it's always like late at
night
later at night on mcdougall like right
in front of ben's pizza okay he'll take
trash cans and block the street just
because he doesn't want people passing
i thought you meant like he like he like
would save parking spots no no
where you can't turn down you can't go
down
mcdougall street at ben's there's like
three
city trash cans in the thing
and some people have gotten out to like
you know a couple of hot shots after a
night out they hop out whatever
and dude he comes with the wrath and
fury of hell really oh what the [ __ ]
like he's crazy he's crazy he's on
another planet this guy he's blocking
the street for you know to keep demons
out or something and when he's like you
know these like finance pro hotshots
don't know what it is and they're like
i'll get out he comes from the wings
dude like [ __ ] like out of the
[ __ ] out of ben's pizza it's like
jeepers creepers [ __ ] [ __ ] he puts
them in their place
they all hop in the back of an uber
because they're like just go straight
well i'll move it and they hop out and
he's like new way oh [ __ ] that i don't
like that at all we're having a block
party with xenu yeah exactly there's
waiting for the rest of the party to
show up that guy
waiting for the comment to land
um
this one's from stormy how long does it
take to drain your drain
at my parents house
our gosh sink upstairs in the kitchen in
the bathroom the bathroom's a tough one
oh my god yeah you it for years it was a
nightmare they had it they got to get
snaked they've had
this and that i don't know what it was
do you ever snake anything yourself
of course yeah snakes a couple of things
snake and toilets go buy go go borrow
the snake from mr o'donald and come back
over and you do the hand you do the hand
one that you turn or you got one of the
mechanical jaws that was the hand one
was the one that he gave us i believe
you're just dude if you have to snake a
toilet you're just
knocking poop around at a high speed
that's all you're doing kippy used to be
a toilet snake i used to have to work
the auger i worked there for three years
yeah the sink upstairs was a tough look
also too now it's all nice but for a
long time i'm listening we didn't have
the stopper in our sink in the bathroom
you know the just a hole just the hole
wow yeah i don't know what happened
that's like 1950 [ __ ]
you just see that no it was supposed to
be there i know but it got thrown out or
something the thing just went up and
down like that
nothing ever popped up
that's real trash yeah yeah yeah the
bathroom was pink at the time too and
fully carpeted
god damn
it was a huge window in the shower um
was it glazed over the glass at least or
the neighbors could just see right in
you could just you have drapes and
blinds in your shower yeah there was a
little curtain there whoa
look out take a peek but it was it's
nice
in like the fall when you're taking a
hot shower and you have the window open
it feels real crispy i'll give you that
yeah
that's all right but i get behind a nice
breeze is when my when my when my little
niblets around you're an outdoor shower
guy you're down you're down the shore
people uh-huh did you see jay larson
just built one our boy jayla is that
what he was doing bill i was wondering
what he was doing in the shower i
messaged him like god damn if that ain't
funny he goes what's better than outdoor
showers it ain't nothing also redid his
dining room or whatever looks [ __ ]
fantastic
that guy jay you want to learn a little
bit about class coming from trash and
becoming classy jay larson check out jay
larson's episode i think he has two
episodes right yeah jay's got two
episodes and [ __ ] kill him real sharp
yeah he knows how to do things real well
i like that yeah does it does his thing
like that that's nice um
but uh my dream today yesterday i think
my wife was like repotting a plant or
something
and i think a lot of soil got in the
dude i mean
it's [ __ ] jammed up and then like
you're like you got the dogs [ __ ]
everywhere so like you don't have time
to like that guy like push away for the
day so it was just kind of like it
slowly drained down and then like
whatever was in there was like stuck on
the side of the bowl
[ __ ] and then i forgot to get drano
which like that stuff can i say
something about drano and those products
that's one of the few things that works
do it i always thought it wouldn't work
they work fantastic it's like where's
billy i think i think i think it's the
worst chemicals in the world
yeah it's kind of like we were talking
about roundup roundup jammed a lot of
people oh yeah that shit's gonna come
back you know oh it's already coming
back
you got to think that's going into the
waist line sure the waistline yeah
yours
sanitary line you should call it if you
want to be properly what i had for what
would you pull a permit over here the
sanitary line what i had for breakfast
is none of your business um
and i think it's like uh
we use it all the time in new york you
got to because all that plumbing's like
stacked on top of each other 400 years
old
so it's like you're dealing with
problems with me talk to city hall
you're dealing with problems from like
[ __ ] you know
yeah the pre before the declaration of
independence was
before nicholas cage saw the declaration
of independence
before broads could vote yeah i don't
know what they were doing we're jammed
up at the moment we always keep a lit we
keep a big bottle and then it's like
dump a third or a half or whatever so we
always got a little laying around but i
got [ __ ] caught my pants down let me
turn you on to this they got crystals
i don't trust them you dump them in
there you you have to use cold water
because if you use hot it'll blow your
bathroom up
i'm telling you it's like the rock in
there i'm gonna be real careful but you
can hear them going
when you put the water in there i do
clean that out no to giving it a
colonoscopy
yeah it's crazy how well that stuff
works i don't get it
doesn't make sense how it works itself
down it's like a jello shot what the
commercial with the clear little thing
going through it works it works i gotta
get some dude with a beard took a [ __ ]
in his sink
that's literally what it looked like
um
some guy who just shaved for the first
time in 20 you dropped a deuce down the
drain
uh all right this one's from mope
haven't had one red yet ever had more
than one antenna on your car
the cell phone johns
yeah the little black ones are the
little squirrely ones they were cool
when you saw that that was a sign of oh
yeah my dad had one of those on his jeep
when he had the he had the phone the car
phone that was like mounted next to like
this shifter that had a cable yeah
pillow uh-huh yeah [ __ ]
we had that
airstrike my my uh my stepdad had a huge
white suburban this thing was like
jacked up big mud tires on it cb radio
[ __ ] this thing had it seemed at the
time like 1500 antennas on it where i'm
like there's not enough electronics in
this thing to make up for the amount of
antennas i think he had those poles to
like make sure that like how high it was
or something like a fishing boat yeah
like the outriggers yeah he had [ __ ] i
don't i didn't [ __ ] get i just
remember being like what do you got
going on in there here's the question
play something from the 18.
that's all i'm all about i would love to
have the 18 van i thought it was cool at
the time my mom hated this thing i
thought it was like riding around a
[ __ ] tank
jumping over the back three seats this
is like you know he made rollouts at
school he made a third row before third
rows were a thing he got two
captains chairs from like another car
really put him on a box and then drill
so this is before third row seating
this couldn't have been like we're
talking about like a wood box yeah
it wasn't safe no
no no no no you're sitting there like
captain kirk oh yeah dude you can get
launched through the windshield and you
could go hyper speed at any time if he
hit those brakes
i seem to have dropped my roll uh yeah
we cruise around there and listen to
bill involved heavy
here's your sign
which by the way
shout out to billingvolt
billingville was great did you know
anybody that had the boomerang antenna
the v one the limo stuff yeah
no
i don't think people had those on reg
regular cars did they maybe i knew a
couple of caddies would have i knew a
dude that had one there was no tv it was
a tercel or something
was that for the tv or was that for like
aerodynamics
was that that was that to reduce drag it
wasn't a spoiler
i don't know it was for a tv really yeah
this kid didn't have a tv in there
though
it was real uh billy mays hayes or
whatever his name was major league the
vw beetle with the rolls royce
shout out to billy mays hayes
okay but you do look like you you
wouldn't have
an antenna but for sure like a little
siren you can put on the roof who the
[ __ ] wouldn't want that that was big
yeah we got you gotta get back to your
police scanner after this yeah
keep tabs on the neighborhood
i gotta get back to the stakeout look
like you have a badge on a chain ready
to bust out training day style yeah
these are all compliments i don't know
what you guys are doing busting train
hoppers down at west fork you just said
in four different ways kippy you look
really cool that's how i took that
kippy you look like a guy who would have
that siren man i got beer i'm athletic
yeah i have a good paying job some sort
of authority it sounds like i got a car
that's probably pretty sweet
you just [ __ ] made my way i just
bought four more of these
all right let's boogie baby let's wrap
it up guys come out to a road show come
out to a show come see us get on the
patreon we [ __ ] love you to death we
appreciate you i love you
i love you and we'll see you next